r
♪ Le voilà qui sourit
sur la place ♪
emps des Fêtes,
c'est l'occasion de célébrer
avec les gens qui nous sont
chers et de partager
de beaux moments
♪ Welcome Christmas ♪
SARAH-ÉMILIE DESCHAMPS,
chanteuse
- Le spectacle, ça devient
une nouvelle tradition
du temps des Fêtes pour nous,
puis maintenant, ça fait partie
de notre... nos routines
et nos traditions familiales.
♪ Petit papa Noël ♪
- Le spectacle réunit sur scène
et en coulisses trois
générations qui partagent
l'amour de la musique
et de l'humour.
JUDI RICHARDS, chanteuse
- C'est touchant.
r avec ses filles, là...
Dans quelques secondes,
je pourrais pleurer à quel point
je suis fière d'elles.
♪ Bonjour, mon année,
née ♪
- Une fierté et un bonheur
partagés par Yvon Deschamps,
qui assistait au premier
concert.YVON DESCHAMPS, humorise
- C'est un moment où on essaie
de créer un peu de magie,
mais c'est aussi le fait qu'on
va être ensemble, sauf en 2020.t
ensemble, et ça, c'est
très important.
- Les spectacles "Noël
chez les Deschamps" mélangent
anecdotes du temps des Fêtes,
chansons originales et airs
classiques de Noël. Le temps
d'un concert, on a l'impression
de faire partie de leur famille.
KARINE DESCHAMPS, chanteuse
- On est tous Grinch à nosheures
raisons, à différentes époques,
mais les mêmes chansons de Noël
nous mettent le même sourire.
♪ I love to wake up... ♪- Noël,n
de penser aux plus démunis.
D'ailleurs, le concert
du 14 décembre sera au bénéfice
de la Fondation Yvon Deschamps
Centre Sud, car il faut savoir
revenir à l'essentiel.
ANNIE DESCHAMPS, humoriste
- Quand on a vu que c'était
un petit peu tro
surconsommation, puis...
En tout cas, moi, j'ai parlé
à mes enfants, puis je leur ai
demandé, t'sais, ce qu'ils
voulaient vraiment pour Noël.
t en fait t en fait t en fait t.
♪ Chaque geste peut guérir ♪
- En effet, ils espèrent
qu'en plus d'un Noël blanc,
nous aurons droit cette année
n Noël vert.
- La planète n'est pas malade,
mais nous, on est en danger
et en grand danger. Il faudrait
que quelqu'un trouve une façond.
- On va chercher.
- La planète n'est pas malade,
mais nous, on risque nos vies.
♪ C'est comme ça Noël
chez les Deschamps ♪
- En plus du disque,
Judi et ses filles partiro
pour une tournée de six dates
dans la grande région
de Montréal. "Noël chez
les Deschamps", c'est l'occasion
de faiux,ux,ux,ux,ux,ux,ux,ux,
de se plonger dans l'ambiance
des Fêtes et une invitation
à partager amour et bonté.
♪ ♪ ♪abi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪ Merry Christmas to yo